hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen now i
love snacks and i know a lot of people
who watch my youtube videos
and my wedding days were surprised by
how often i
snack because diet culture has made
snacking out to be a
bad habit but in reality planning
healthy
balanced satiating snacks can help you
get from one meal to the next
with stable energy better digestion
and without the need to overdo it when
you do get there so before we get into
this
don't forget to subscribe and ring the
little bell so you never
miss out on a recipe and of course a
quick disclaimer that the information
in this video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare professional about your
unique
needs okay so a few major questions that
i want to tackle
before i get into some of my favorite
snack recipes
number one what should you snack on
honestly
whatever you want i like to think about
snacks more like mini meals so
if you like having something for a meal
why not just have
a smaller version of that as a snack so
snacks can be savory or they can be
sweet but since one of the big
conspiracy theories floating around is
that i am anti-fruit
or that i restrict my kids fruit both of
which are hilariously
untrue i thought we would focus the
recipes on fruit
forward snacks so first things first i'm
not anti-fruit at all but obviously
i'm also not a fan of restrictive fruit
only diets like fruitarian
or frugivore and as a dietitian that
should be a given
i actually think fruit alone is a really
great snack
but when i make suggestions about adding
to a snack that is just
straight up fruit i'm trying to think
about an
optimal snack for satiety and variety
to give you all some ideas on what you
can do at home to boost things
up again it's not about taking away the
fruit
it's about what can i add so what i'm
looking to up the staying power in a
snack
i want to combine two or more of the
following
fiber healthy fat and protein
i call this the hunger crushing
combination
and i know a lot of you guys have heard
me say that term before
now fruit on its own is typically a
great source of fiber
with some options having more fiber than
others
and it's also packed with antioxidants
so of course
this is a great snack choice all on its
own
and when i need something super small to
get me by
of course a handful of berries is really
all that i want or need
but for times that i need something more
substantial
we can optimize that fruit snack and
make it more saturating
by adding in either some protein some
healthy fats
or both next how big
is a snack versus a meal so like i said
i kind of like to think of snacks as
minnie meals not just as
treats there's definitely room for
treats or what i prefer to call
fun foods but they're not the same thing
as a snack so the size or number of
calories
in that snack is going to totally vary
based on the person and how hungry that
they are in that moment
but if we're using one of our meals as a
guide
most people would probably be satisfied
on a snack that's between
a quarter and a half of the size of
their typical meal
so just as an example if you're having
600
calorie meals that might mean a snack
that's between let's say 150
and 300 calories approximately again
this is all semantics and it does not
matter what you call a snack
or a meal if you're listening to your
hunger cues as i know that some people
will just prefer to have
you know equal sized mini meals
throughout the day
it really doesn't matter as long as
you're meeting your nutrient needs
for the day because honestly everyone's
preference for how often they eat
or how much to eat in each meal or snack
will totally vary
but i am just trying to give you a very
general guide for those of you who like
to plan out
your meals and your snacks because
you're on the go and you need to make
space to refuel between those more
formal family
meals okay final question where
should you snack now i would say ideally
in the same place or the same kinds of
places
that you would eat a meal of course
there are times we're going to get busy
and we need to eat while we're walking
or at our desk or in our car etc but
if we really want to zone in on those
hunger and fullness cues
i do suggest trying to sit down and
schedule time for an
uninterrupted quiet snack okay
so without a do here are four of my
favorite balanced
fruity snacks that are not just oh put
some almond butter on a slice of apple
and call it a day
let's do this
okay so the first recipe i'm going to
share is for my protein
ice cream this is basically two
ingredients and actually
this recipe is in the mindful glow
cookbook which
shameless plug here folks if you haven't
gotten this book you need to get it
so i'll leave a link of course below so
you can find this on amazon super easily
but it is so simple and you can use any
kind of fruit that you have
i have frozen mango and we know in covid
times especially
you know frozen is so much easier to
find than fresh and to keep on hand
especially if you're not going back and
forth
to the grocery store a million times a
day so basically i'm going to throw in
my frozen mango escape
mango just like that into a mini food
processor
blender whatever you've got
probably i'm going to be able to fit and
i'm using cottage cheese now cos cheese
is packed with protein and if you don't
like the little lumpy
kind of texture of cots cheese that's
why we put in the food processor and it
gets
super creamy and smooth so this is like
nice cream on steroids as far as i'm
concerned
um it's a really really satisfying snack
i love this right before bed
all right i'm gonna throw this in
because we can fit it in there
okay and then that is all you actually
need
depending on the sweetness of your fruit
and if you want to make this um
sweeter you can add a little bit of
honey i sometimes do i sometimes don't
that's probably all it needs if any um
all right
let's blend this up
there's a lump at the top that needs to
be pushed down
and you know if there's lumps or little
bits of fruit left in there
totally okay love that too i love a
little texture
so good it's literally like the froyo
that you would get
from those old school frozen yogurt
shops where they put the block of yogurt
in you choose your fruit
and they press it down that's what this
tastes like to me
super creamy so refreshing for hot days
yum now this here alone is satisfying
actually all three of my hunger crushing
compounds
we've got my fiber we've got my protein
and we've got some fats in there
but if you want to take it up a notch
and make it even more satisfying
we can put some little toppers on here
because everything is better with some
sprinkles and toppings right
so we got some hemp hearts
we've got some little bits of seeds i've
got like a seed mix here
and some crushed pistachios so good
yum
okay so next i'm gonna do my fruity
oh baby baby's just getting excited
about these spring rolls
we're gonna do so we're gonna do my
fruity quinoa spring rolls so
when it's hot outside i love a good
summer roll or
cold roll usually you have them with
some kind of like
noodle or rice in there with some
veggies and like a peanut dip
i thought why not make them fruity and
make them into like some kind of like a
really easy snack
so that's what we're gonna do and
actually this also doubles as an amazing
breakfast that my whole family loves
so first thing i've done is i've cooked
some quinoa
you can use rice you can use even
oatmeal any kind of grain will work here
that you just already have batch prepped
in the fridge this is something that
i'll do like a whole big batch of at the
beginning of the week
and then i divvy it up into you know
stir fries or bowls or
making spring rolls like this so we're
going to put this into a bowl
just like that
[Music]
great and any kind of nut butter this is
basically our glue it's going to stick
everything together
so any kind of natural nut butter peanut
butter
cashew better almond butter sunflower
butter
doesn't matter maybe not regular butter
butter
but any other butter will do so very
carefully
i'm gonna try not to make a mess but i
probably will
so i'm gonna try to mix this together
very gingerly
quinoa is one of those grains that gets
everywhere
try feeding a toddler quinoa and not
expecting to have to clean up
a massive mess afterwards it's a
nightmare
but worth it worth it when it's
delicious
and nutrient dense like this oh my
goodness okay so it's basically sticking
all the grains together
like sticky rice kind of but with peanut
butter flavored
okay so i've got these little rice
papers
and i'm going to soak them into some
warm
water just give them a gentle massage
it's like a little spa day for the rice
paper wraps
something that i could really use about
now if you know what i mean
but you know i'm in a giving mood
so give it a nice little rub down
just like that you can flip it over and
basically you're looking for it to
become
very pliable but not so
loose and kind of wet that you can't
work with it anymore so that's
that's feeling about good so i'll show
you what it looks like
carefully so that it doesn't all fall on
top of each other just like that
i'm gonna put this down onto my cutting
board or even just onto
the the counter super easy we're going
to add in
some of our nutty quinoa
into like a log shape and then any fruit
that you have you could use banana you
could use berries you could use a
variety like i'm doing right here make
it look pretty
um it doesn't need to be instagram
worthy let's be real it's all just going
into
this this thing right here
so throw it together like that any kind
of fruit will work
but of course more color always equals
you know more fun
so that looks good then add crunchy
things
we love crunchy things obviously i've
got a variety of crunchy things
in my pantry that i always have we've
got hemp hearts
we've got nuts we've got seeds we've got
some coconut that i toasted
this looks so good all right
so very carefully and this is this is
honestly not my forte but
you're going to try to wrap all that
goodness into
the rice paper wrap
fold in the sides just like that
roll it up as tightly as you can
this is where i usually fail and i
usually fail hard
but it doesn't matter it's all delicious
just
like that there
you got your rice paper
summer roll spring roll concoction
i just want to eat this but i know i'm
going to make some more so i can show
you how beautiful they look on the plate
so let's make some more
and i've got some yogurt for dipping so
you could do plant-based yogurt
you can do regular yogurt you can do no
yogurt it is delicious no matter what
but i like everything with a dip
everything is more tasty and more fun
with a dip
so good
crunchy fruity peanut buttery
it's ticking all the boxes here folks
and
we've got we've got our fiber got our
protein
and we've got our healthy fats ding ding
ding
this is awesome yeah
that's safer for the hero shop so hard
so hard not to be a glutton here all
right
okay snack recipe number three is my
banana
roll up pops now actually this recipe is
also in the mindful glow cookbook just
saying
and it is really delicious it's a fan
favorite in my house
and something that is super versatile
just based on whatever you have on hand
so we've got some whole grain tortillas
right here
large ones and i've got some any kind of
nut butter we've got almond butter in
this case give it a good smear
this is your glue this is your banana
glue and also
who doesn't love banana and nut butter
it's just
a natural combo just like this
baby is kicking just excited about
the combinations here okay
that's gonna have to do
does it bother you that i'm licking my
fingers
i'm gonna eat this so this is just for
me all right banana
happen to be really ripe bananas which
is how i like them and i want no green
bananas up in here
so this is going down right into the
center and then we add some more
toppings yay
yay for toppings anything you have i've
got some
dried fruit dried cranberries i like a
little more fruit action i like that
kind of tangy sour combination with the
sweet banana
that looks good i've got some high fiber
cereal because i like a crunch factor
this is actually my favorite part of it
so i just crushed
some so the high fiber kind of like all
brand
cereal i love that
that's my this is my favorite part of it
factor what what
all right more hand parts because as you
all know
i'm obsessed i put this on everything
nuts if you want
coconut all right
now we roll roll rolling with the homies
who knows that reference if you know
that reference we can be friends
straighten out that banana straight now
okay nice and tight
getting lots of rolling skills here
folks
tight tight tight just like that
because of that nut butter it all sticks
together
all right let's cut this guy in half
because this is going to make two pops
just like that
see how yum yum that looks
run away cranberry all right and because
everything is way tastier on a
on a popsicle stick yes you could eat
this just like this obviously it's
delicious
no rules but i'm putting it on a
popsicle stick
i'm gonna pop these into the freezer for
a hot minute because i've got a really
special
topping that's gonna go on top okay so i
just took these out of the freezer
they've only just kind of chilled it
just helps the chocolate set a little
faster
and i've got some melted dark chocolate
now this is a totally optional step
but in my books not optional so
a little dippy dip just just the tip
just the top there like that and then
you can get in there
with whatever toppings that you like
i've got some
uh coconut and some very finely minced
pistachios so yummy
oh good mmm
yes this is delicious
and again fiber healthy fats
and protein all the good stuff
and it's so so good
okay and finally we're gonna do my power
pb and j
toast now this is something that i make
often for breakfast but it also makes a
really
healthy hearty satisfying snack so
we're going to make our own sweetened
peanut butter and this is something i
actually kind of
invented for my son who well prefers the
sweetened
peanut butter to the natural variety but
he loves this power peanut butter
so i've got regular old peanut butter
again use whatever nut butter you like
sun butter also works if you've got
allergies
just like that and i'm going to use half
of a banana
a really ripe one and honestly if you
have
a banana that even has a bruise it
doesn't matter because you're gonna mash
it up
so look at this doesn't matter gonna
mash it up
though this one looks kind of gnarly so
maybe i'll pass on this one
i've got the other half right here so
let's use the nice looking half but
honestly it doesn't matter because
once you mash it up anyways it basically
goes brown so
that's great a really ripe banana this
is going to add the natural sweetness
plus of course it's going to add some
fruit
and some healthy carbs mash all that
together
and i'll make a batch of this in the
last few days in the fridge and you can
make sandwiches you can make toast
so good also gonna add in some flax so
for those healthy fats
and a little bit more fiber and protein
that is a roasted golden golden flax and
oh my goodness it smells so good
all right this is looking good just like
that
nice and thick this is delicious
on toast oatmeal yogurt you name it
it's so so good all right now let's make
our toast
i feel like most you know how to make
toast put in the toaster amazing pops up
isn't it a wonderful thing a little bit
of that
on the bottom here
just like that
now you could leave it just like that i
mean it is delicious we've got
we've got we're taking all the boxes in
my box right
but i also love the combination of
peanut butter and
jam so if you watched my video
right here you probably saw me make my
chia jam which is again one of our
family staples it's something that i
make several times a week
every week just depending on whatever
fruit or frozen fruit i have on hand so
today i had
sour cherries so good and this recipe
could not be
simpler i will leave a link to it below
it's a really popular recipe on my blog
but in this case i used sour cherries
chia
i cooked the cherries down you can even
do it in the microwave smash them up
um add a little bit of lemon juice or
lime juice if you want
you can add a little sweetener if you
want you don't have to
and then just add in the um the chia and
it thickens the whole thing up
so i'm gonna add some of this on top
oh yeah this is so good
yum yum yum again
great on its own but i got some hemp
parts here so i'm gonna
hit it with some sprinkles on top we
call these sprinkles in my house
my son's always asks for sprinkles and
so i'll give him his own little bowl
and he can add his own and sometimes he
just like takes a shot of
sprinkles and i'm not gonna stop them
right
this is great so that is looking
good check that out folks
so good lots of healthy fats
lots of healthy carbs fiber rich carbs
and lots of protein as well
well loves that is all that i got for
you today if you like this
super casual food prep style video where
i'm just kind of talking you through the
motions
without like a huge amount of editing
and production
please please please give this video the
thumbs up so that i know
that you liked it and also if there are
other meal ideas that you're looking for
a video for let me know in the comments
below and until then of course subscribe
to the channel and i will see you next
time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you